Traditional machine learning approaches have
been difficult to apply to genetics problems
and problems in genomics because these traditional
approaches have often assumed really really
large sample sizes which we simply don't have.
There are a huge number of variables that
we measure for every single individual, for
example, all the mutations in your genotype,
all of the different gene expression levels
for individual cell types, individual tissues,
all the different phenotypes, so every single
disease you may or may not be diagnosed with,
and all of these different features have really
complex structures.
And while machine learning methods are incredibly
good at modeling those structures, they require
a huge amount of data, a huge amount of independent
samples to be able to get really nice signal
back from them.We simply don't have that in
genomics.
My group has been developing a lot of great
approaches to try and add additional structure
to these models to be able to exploit what
structure there is in these complex highly
correlated features that we have like gene
expression and like genotype data in order
to exploit the few samples that we have as
much as possible.
Another big difference is actually labeled
data.
So a lot of traditional machine learning approaches
use supervised data, in other words they have
ground truth, they know the truth about what's
the underlying signals so if you think about
emails we often have a bunch of emails that
have either a spam or a not spam label on
them.
And we can learn predictive models for future
emails.
But we also don't have these high quality
labeled data sets in genomics, we simply don't
know exactly which mutation causes most diseases,
we don't know which mutation affects gene
expression levels in particular tissues.
We know maybe the range, we know maybe a large
set of them, we don't know the exact one,
and that really causes us to need to think
about different types of models for the genomic
data sets that have no ground truth to them.
My group generally thinks about unsupervised
problems, so we're more interested in thinking
about different patterns that we find in the
data as opposed to doing predictive models.
So we're interested in thinking about very,
very small signals, very small patterns that
we find in the data that may indicate, for
example propensity for disease, so looking
at small changes in gene expression levels,
correlated gene expression levels that may
be indicative for example of thyroid cancer,
or of Alzheimer's disease.
The key about these types of models is that
there is a lot of differences in each of the
individuals in the world, every single person
has a lot of small patterns that we could
find but really we're interested in finding
the ones that are indicative of disease.